and Marie Cox what are your thoughts on
purchasing leads to create new business
oh ma I'm gonna I'm gonna come out
strong on this one and say it's a real
no no what we what I can tell you this
is this from from the email marketing
side of things again is I speak slowly
from that but when you boil it down what
you're looking for in an email is is
subscriber engagement now when that
subscriber comes to your site and and
clicks in an dobson they're receiving
your communication and you send them an
email to confirm that subscription and
you're really starting that that journey
and you're really growing with that
customer and your thus increasing the
likelihood of higher subscriber
engagement and a conversion down the
road whether that be a purchase a vote
it could be a million different things
when when you purchase leads you have
none in that you don't know what you're
getting into and from email service
providers framework many of the email
service providers out there actually
won't even be able to work with you I
know for a fact they Weber cannot work
with anyone that's purchased a list or
any type of leads so I'm gonna say it's
you're better off building your your
list over a long haul that are your
building from a higher echelon if you
will of subscribers that are engaged in
to what you're saying or what you're
selling then you are going out and
purchasing purchasing a lesson Evan what
were your thoughts there yeah yeah I'm
with you on that um I like you know
doing the golden rule you treat people
like you'd like to be treated and I hate
being spammed so why would I span people
I hate being cold called why would I
cold call people okay I mean I guess it
can work for some people and I think
it's becoming less and less and less
effective but I try to do things that
I'm I would be receptive to if I saw it
I'll throw a curveball and I a friend of
mine is doing something interesting
where he is using lists in a different
way he'll buy a list of names so
trying to target firefighters for
example who borrows firefighters and
you'll never email them but he'll upload
the list to facebook so you can track
and he'll show targeted ads when they
come on facebook okay so it's a slightly
different way of doing it and and if I
go on Facebook you know I don't mind
seeing ads related to entrepreneurship
but I definitely wouldn't want you
emailing me or calling me I don't have a
phone I just have a voicemail yeah I
don't have a cell phone either um and
that's maybe going kind of extreme but I
don't like being interrupted which would
it all comes down to and so you know you
are interrupting your potential clients
you're starting off uh you know on a
negative note which yet I really hate so
i'm not a big i'm not a big fan